leurs scandales fantastiques s'élèvent à zéro
vous êtes celui qui n'a jamais triché sur
sa déclaration de revenus Duffy a triché un peu plus
tard sur sa déclaration de revenus et vous en faites
un problème désolé les hivers
attendront un peu avec quoi pourquoi
pensez-vous qu'il n'a pas le droit de poser des questions sur
l'accord qu'il croit mr.  Harper savait pourquoi
pensez-vous que m.  Harper n'en savait pas
parce que ce n'est pas un accord, c'est un rien
Harper ne lit pas les formulaires d'impôt sur le revenu,
idiot, c'est fait par les gens du
département des impôts, mais vous ne croyez pas que
quelqu'un d'autre dans ce bureau était au courant de
cela  Eiling nous l'avons, tu triches plus
sur tes impôts que Duffy ne l'a jamais fait pourquoi
dirais-tu que je vois un membre mentir une
merde ouais et toi aussi pourquoi dirais-tu
que tu fais un problème de Duffy
c'est un rien que Harper a produit de bon
gouvernement c'est rien c'est rien mais
c'est zéro et rien rien rien mais
s'il savait tu crois que d'autres
personnes dans le bureau et tu sais je
pense que tu es une merde de mensonges et
tes médias avec toi quel est ton nom
don '  t bourre bien ça placera